hello everyone and welcome to a very
important game from round 13 of the feta
candidates tournament 2022 it's Yanni
publisher versus Richard Rapport for
some reason it says Rapport news uh yeah
probably because I had a Magnus game uh
in the previous video so sorry about
that uh but yeah against 300 Rapport and
the situation in the tournament is
currently uh that Jan only needs a draw
from his next two games in order to
qualify for the World cheers
championship match he has a two-point
lead if you guys remember uh he's an
eight and a half and uh Ding and
Nakamura are following with six and a
half so only if Yan loses uh both of his
games he has this game against Rapport
and the final round game he has against
Yankees to do that with the black pieces
only then uh duding and Hikaru have a
chance of catching up the nepo if they
win both of their games in the
penultimate and ultimate rounds but this
game uh well we will shed some light on
what that does that even matter yeah so
let's check it out and then we are going
to discuss what happens next and what
does this mean for the uh for the entire
wheelchair Championship cycle so Jan has
the white pieces and he opens with E4
and everyone thought okay of course the
rapper does not have a chance of
qualifying uh this is going to be a
quick quick Berlin drama or most likely
E5 is is coming next but not a rapport
please Pawn to C5 he goes for the
Sicilian Defense and here Nepal thought
uh all right I I have to play I'm not
gonna just be uh you know cruising
through the uh to the last two runs
getting uh at least a draw and a certain
qualification so Knight to F3 we have
Knight to C6 and pawn to D4 uh we have C
captures Knight captures Knight to F6
Knight to C3 and D6 now this is the
classical variation and the bishop to G5
the incredibly sharp Richter Rouser
variation against the Sicilian E6 by an
upward Queen to D2 and now Pawn to A6 so
this is the absolute main line uh
nothing new Happening Here we have
castles in the bishop to D7 now at some
point um
you will be able to capture and the four
put the bishop on on D6 or even uh in
some lines maybe even the Knight comes
the E5 or white captures then you get
your Bishop to C6 but uh Bishop to D7 a
standard idea and now the uh absolute
main line is spawned to F4 but we have
the immediate Knight captures on C4
Bayan Bishop captures and F3 and the
interesting thing about this particular
variation without going the uh with the
aggressive F4 is that white uh hasn't
really lost a game in this line with
this exact same position and okay H6
challenging the bishop we have Bishop to
F4 and now D5 uh black gets the execute
the very early D5 and you guys know that
if that happens in the ceiling usually
black has nothing to worry about uh but
Jan isn't looking for an adventure here
he just needs a clean draw and that's it
Queen back to E1 now opening up the
default for the white rook and also
putting the queen and the same file as
the king with Bishop to B4 pinning the
Knight and pawn to A3 not challenging
the bishop a report trade the bishop
captures Queen captures and here at
Robert castles with Bishop to E5 now
threatening to mess up black spawn
structure here and you don't really have
a way of dealing with this you could
play something like uh
Knights the D7 it's uh it might even be
a tricky move but uh yeah of course Jan
would not capture on G7 if you capture
on G7 right away then Queen to G5 check
and you lose that Bishop but even
without blundering uh Knight 37 isn't
all that impressive we can play Bishop
to D6 and it's a very fine idea Rook to
E8 E5 and the bishop here it will just
be very annoying for a very long time so
okay Rook the C8 by Rapport and now
Bishop captures and F6 this cannot be
avoided uh G captures is adventurous but
it would just allow Yan to you know get
a better position very early on in the
game for example Rook D2 we defend the
C2 pawn and then we start bringing the
queen into again we start pushing pawns
and uh you know maybe win the game so a
report trades Queens a queen captures an
F6 and Jan very happy with this turn of
events captures captures and now e
captures on D5 Bishop captures and now
Rook to D4 preparing the bishop and to
bring the add The Rook over to D1 so
here there is a game where Rook the C5
was played but here we have F5 and it is
now as of move 19 that we have a
completely new game uh so Bishop to D3
already with a thread just bash of
capture spawn captures and we win upon
so Bishop back to C6 and now yam plays a
rook at D1 we have King to G7 and the
bishop back to E2 so now the Rooks are
nicely controlling the D file and there
is absolutely zero Advantage for either
player here but uh nipple cannot lose
this uh you know that doesn't matter
what happens you you cannot lose this
position so by this uh well probably
even sooner in nepo knew that he would
get an easy draw here and qualify for
the World cheers championship match so
King to F6 we have um Rook to H4 going
after the H6 Pawn King G5 G3 and now
Rook F to d8 offering a rook trade Nepal
uh forces a rook trade but by doubling
up on the D file Rook characters with
Rook captures and now Pawn to E5
grabbing more space here but it doesn't
matter here if Nepal moves the rook and
allows F4 it could go
wrong for him but he doesn't allow that
of course F4 would check and now it's
perfectly fine he captures real captures
with Bishop to E4 and just C3 defending
of course the the C2 Pawn we have rooked
the d8 now and Bishop to D1 uh you have
to you don't want to allow a position
for example where this bishop comes here
that could be very annoying and this
King will be trapped on C1 for the rest
of the game and then you know bad things
might happen so here just bash up to D1
uh we rooked the D7 and Bishop to C2
once this bishop gets traded off it is a
draw and there there's nothing more to
be done here so rookie 7 uh trying to uh
trying to undouble his pawns but now
nipple just goes Bishop back to D1 and
the Rapport of course it means that
there is no more pointing continuing
Rook to D7 Bishop to C2 Rook to E7 and
the bishop to D1 and he was in this
position on move 34 that Yani polishi
and Richard Rapport agreed to a draw
which means that Jan now
uh has one more round to go but uh it
doesn't matter one round before the end
of the candidate tournament the
animation is the winner of the feeder
candidates tournament and he will be the
one who will be playing for the title of
world champion in 2023 when the match is
scheduled uh however we still do not
know who he will be playing against
because Magnus Carlson as he said he
might not be interested in playing
another worldshire championship match uh
because it's a very very exhausting and
you know you have to be extremely
motivated it takes a lot of preparation
and uh for him when he has to defend the
title every two years it takes a big
chunk of his life you know every two
years and maybe he's just not all that
interested in it I mean uh he wanted so
many times that um uh you know we'll
we'll see even though Magnus said this
no one actually believes this because
they're still uh you know uh of course
everyone thinks he wants to be world
champion for as long as possible and you
know we cannot maybe 27 years like
Lasker but those were different times
the uh back then you you could choose
your opponents and you could uh you know
uh pretty much uh uh dictate the the
terms of of the candidates tournament
when it will be where it elect pretty
much everything but now we have the
governing body that is feeding and you
know it happens every two years fairly
irregularly uh so yeah that's pretty
much it Yani promise you will be playing
against either Magnus or whoever uh
places second in the feeder candidates
tournament like we said uh these were
the standings before the final two
rounds so uh Nakamura and the ding with
uh six and a half points are the only
uh well well not not the only but uh
have the best chance of uh of qualifying
so it's still going to be very very
intense rajabo still has a chance Corona
still has a chance I think for a rapper
to do that and all it is uh the chance
no longer exists uh so yeah we'll see
what happens uh I will cover at least
one more game from around 13 Even though
the the tournament is now basically
decided in Jan's favor uh but what do
you guys think uh will Magnus play this
will uh there was an interview with
Magnus Carlsen
um before this round they asked him if
uh he you know if he changed his mind if
he is impressed with nepo's play he said
that he's extremely impressed with
nepo's performance he's been uh
extremely uh dominant even though some
of the games uh you know appear as if
players played weaker against him but
that's you know you've heard of the
Magnus effect there's also the nepo
effect against nepo uh people just play
weird stuff and you know that they go uh
in you know into his territory where
it's you know his happy hunting ground
and they just get destroyed in in
Miniatures but that's a Nepal style
we'll see if he will play against Magnus
if that will be something that changes
or will he continue in the style that he
played in the previous World Church
championship match or will he maybe try
something else maybe a bit more solid
but I think he will still continue with
his chest because that's what brought
him here it's very hard to imagine that
he can reinvent his style for the uh for
the match against Magnus and uh probably
he doesn't even want to or or you know
pretty much no one wants him to do that
everyone just loves nipple style and
they want him to throw dad at Magnus but
at the absolute highest level and then
you know we can enjoy some brilliant
chess uh so yeah once again I hope you
guys enjoyed it what do you guys think
will happen will we have um you know
completely someone who is not Magnus
playing the wheelchair Champion to match
in 2023 or will Magnus play that's it
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jeffrey cook Abhishek Gregory
Thomas gay in Franklin and Jim Tran for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the candidates until it
finishes uh so stay tuned for that and
if you haven't seen it uh below I will
link two games the Magnus played
yesterday one against Anish Geary one
against Judith Polgar uh really awesome
games do check them out see you soon